THAT MEANS NO PLACE
TO PUT OUR BONERS,
EXCEPT IN OUR HANDS...
AGAIN.
- IT'S NOT AS FUN--I'VE GOT
CALLOUSES FROM WORKING OUT.
- I DON'T KNOW--MAYBE WE SHOULD
JUST GET OUR SNACKS AT 7-ELEVEN.
THAT'S WHAT WE ALWAYS DO.
- WHAT?
- 7-ELEVEN DOESN'T HAVE PARTY
TINS FULL OF POPCORN, OKAY?
THAT'S WHAT KARL ASKED FOR.
ALL I'M SAYING IS WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE LIVING
THAT CRAZY COSTCO LIFE.
- I KNOW.
- I DON'T KNOW IF I'VE EVER
TOLD YOU GUYS THIS STORY,
BUT I SNUCK INTO A COSTCO
WHEN I WAS A KID.
- YEAH, WE'VE HEARD THAT STORY.
- YEAH.
- IT WAS THE MOST MAGNIFICENT
EXPERIENCE OF MY LIFE.
THERE WAS GIANT TRAMPOLINES
HANGING FROM THE CEILING.
LIKE, SHAMPOO BOTTLES
THAT ARE, LIKE...
all: THE SIZE
OF MY MASSIVE THIGHS.
- I ONLY GOT, LIKE,
15 FEET IN,
THEN I WAS TACKLED
BY SECURITY.
- [laughs]
BUT IT WAS--
IT WAS, HONESTLY, THE BEST
40 SECONDS OF MY LIFE.
- YEAH.
- WE'VE HEARD THIS STORY.
- WELL, THEN
WHY DIDN'T YOU STOP ME?
- I DIDN'T STOP YOU
BECAUSE I LIKE THE STORY,
AND IT GOT ME JACKED UP
ABOUT SOME KIRKLAND JEANS
THAT I WANT, MAN.
- THAT'S PART OF THE STORY!
- THE WIDE LEGS,
THE THICK DENIM.
- THE ELASTIC WAISTBANDS.
- MM-HMM.
- 'CAUSE YOU'RE GONNA WANT
TO HAVE A FEW SNACKS
WHILE YOU'RE THERE.
- AND IF YOU GET 'EM
WITHOUT THE POCKETS
ON THE BACK, NO SNAGGIN'.
- THAT'S--
THOSE ARE WOMEN'S JEANS. YEAH.
- WELL, THEY JUST SIT BETTER
ON MY HIPS.
- YOU DO HAVE
A VERY WOMANLY FIGURE.
- I HAVE WHAT I HAVE.
- YOU ALSO HAVE TITS.
- NICE SKIN.
- YOU KNOW, QUITE FRANKLY...
I'M WILLING TO MARCH
INTO ALICE'S OFFICE RIGHT NOW
AND SAY...
[deep voice] "I QUIT."
- RIGHT?
- "I'M GONNA GO BE
A COSTCO SECURITY GUARD."
[normal voice] I MIGHT JUST USE
MY REGULAR VOICE, THOUGH.
I DON'T KNOW.
- OR...
WE STEAL THE SNACKS
FROM THE BREAK ROOM.
OCEAN'S ELEVEN AND THIRTEEN
THIS BITCH.
- [bleep] OCEAN'S TWELVE!
- YEAH.
- TOTAL MISFIRE.
- ALL RIGHT, LAST ONE, WAYMOND.
PUT YOUR HAND OUT.
NO ONE LIKES A GUMMI SLUT.
GET OUT OF HERE.
- HEY, JILLIAN.
COULD I PLEASE GET FOUR
LOW-SODIUM STRING CHEESES?
- WELL, YOU'VE ALREADY HIT
YOUR SNACK LIMIT FOR THE DAY.
NOW HIT THE ROAD.
- [chuckles]
JILLIAN, I DON'T THINK
YOU UNDERSTAND.
I'M, LIKE, THE BIGGEST DUDE
IN THIS OFFICE.
- OKAY, WELL, MY BEST OFFER
IS SEVEN GRAPES.
- HEY, JILLIAN.
- HMM?
- [bleep] YO' GRAPES!
- I'M JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE
WE'VE GOT
ALL OUR DUCKS IN A ROW HERE,
UH, YOU KNOW, BECAUSE BASICALLY,
THE WAY I'M LOOKING AT IT--
YEAH. NO, I KNOW.
BUT TRUST ME,
THE DEAL IS ALMOST DONE.
- HEY, JILLIAN, UM,
DO YOU HAVE THE KEYS
TO THE STORAGE CLOSET?
- WHAT FOR?
- I JUST NEED TO VACUUM
SOMETHING.
- UH, WHAT SOMETHING?
- [laughs]
UM, WELL,
IT'S JUST THAT, UH...
[whispers]
I WANTED TO SHAVE MY NIPPLES.
BUT THEY'RE, LIKE,
KIND OF HAIRY,
SO I DON'T WANT
TO GET HAIR EVERYWHERE.
- [moaning]
[knock on stall door]
A LITTLE PRIVACY, BUDDY!
I'M OBVIOUSLY MASTURBATING
RIGHT NOW--IT HURTS.
FEELS LIKE RAZOR BLADES
ARE COMING OUT THE TIP.
JUST KIDDING.
I'M POOPING HERE!
OH! WHOO!
WHAT DID I EAT--ROCKS?
ALICE.
OH, I'VE GOT SOME...
PRETTY GROSS NEWS.
I, ON ACCIDENT, DROPPED
AN ATOM BOMB IN THE BATHROOM,
AND THE TOILET WAS DESTROYED,
SO THAT IS ON ME.
AND I KNOW A PLUMBER
WHO'S GONNA TAKE CARE OF IT.
AND YOU LOOK AWESOME TODAY,
BY THE WAY.